à l'image de la saison les arbres du
parc du fonds sont à l'automne de leur
vie
lohan f a dressé un bilan de santé
préoccupant 80% des 434 arbres doivent
être abattus ils sont trop vieux ou
malades atteints par des champignons les
armillaire certains menaçaient de tomber
à tout moment ils ont été abattus dès
décembre 2015 et à ce constat sur les
treize terrasse du parc s'ajoutent 16
points de maçonnerie recensés comme
potentiellement dangereux pour le public
comme ici sous l'église sainte urs
il ya des traces est plus ancienne du
parc buffon du 11e siècle et c'est un
lieu en effet assez symptomatique
puisqu'à la fois la végétation a repris
le dessus
la sécurité pose des difficultés très
importantes pour la structure même de
l'église
donc face à tout ça il faut trouver des
solutions à la fois pour réaménager
sécurisée et en profiter pour ré
embellir et réenchanter celui la mairie
de montbard a donc lancé une longue
série d'études et d'enquêtés pour
redonner au lieu son attrait d'antan le
tout vient d'aboutir sur un schéma
directeur d'aménagement pour ce site de
5 hectares classé monument historique
l'objectif est de retrouver sans le
copier l'esprit d'origine voulue par le
comte de buffon ici derrière moi avec le
cabinet travail de buffon c'est là où
c'est écrit l'histoire naturelle et
l'histoire naturelle c'est vraiment une
notion a convoqué aujourd'hui pour nous
interroger à nouveau sur l'avenir
et quelle vocation écologique on va
donner à ce lieu en faire vraiment un
lieu expérimental très écologique dans
son approche
et puis bien sûr qu'il soit aussi un
lieu très agréable pour tous les usages
qui qui qui s'y trouvent
les gens qui viennent s'y promener les
touristes qui viennent le découvrir les
travaux de maçonnerie débuteront dès
avant la création l'année suivante d'un
espace pédagogique et récréatif ici même
et une succession de travaux par la
suite de quoi permettre la renaissance
de ce parc buffon qui doit aussi scellé
l'an prochain un partenariat prometteur
avec le muséum national d'histoire
naturelle de paris